Veamos si podemos dividir 5.005 ÷ 7 y ver cuál
es el resultado. De modo que podemos reescribir
esto como 5.005 dividido entre 7, y la clave
aquí es no perder de vista el punto decimal,
pero aparte de eso realmente lo resolveremos
como un problema tradicional de división larga.
De modo que vamos a poner el punto decimal
a la derecha de la posición de las unidades,
así que está justo aquí, sólo ponemos el
punto decimal justo encima del punto decimal,
y ahora lo resolveremos como un problema
tradicional de división larga. Entonces
¿cuántas veces cabe 7 en 5? Bueno el 7 cabe
0 veces en 5, y podemos escribir 0 x 7 es
0. Hagamos el proceso completo sólo para mostrar
que funciona: 0 x 7 es 0, restamos y obtenemos 5,
obtenemos el 5 que tenemos aquí, y luego podemos
bajar otro 0, bajamos este 0 que tenemos aquí;
entonces nos preguntamos ¿cuántas veces cabe 7
en 50? Bueno, 7 x 7 = 49 así que cabe 7 veces,
7 x 7 = 49, restamos y el resultado es 1.
Ahora podemos bajar este 0, vamos a hacer eso:
7 cabe en 10 una vez, 1 x 7 es 7, restamos y
obtenemos 3. Ahora, finalmente, podemos bajar este
5, bajamos el 5 y nos preguntamos ¿cuántas veces
cabe 7 en 35? Bueno, 5 x 7 = 35, cabe 5 veces,
5 x 7 = 35, restamos y terminamos. Lo hemos
dividido por completo, entonces 5.005 ÷ 7 = 0.715.